al cumplirse los 100 días de mandato de
rodrigo chaves el presidente enfrentó la
primera manifestación masiva miles de
estudiantes y empleados de las cinco
universidades públicas reclamaban ante
el intento del gobierno de recortar en
un 23 por ciento el fondo para la
educación superior poco después las
autoridades anunciaron que no habría
rebajó y se mantendrá el presupuesto de
este año como base para negociar el
presupuesto del año que viene de la
educación superior pública en su
discurso emitido este 16 de agosto
chávez destacó lo que considera son sus
primeros logros como la reducción de los
impuestos de la importación del arroz y
la rebaja del costo de las revisiones
técnicas vehiculares para la población
así como una declaratoria de interés
público de una mesa que construya una
política pública para pueblos indígenas
chávez también anunció acciones próximas
a tomar como la venta de un par de
bancos estatales una propuesta para un
tope al precio de los combustibles
mejorar la atención médica en el sistema
de seguridad social proyectos de
ampliación de infraestructura
simplificar el régimen tributario y
proponer un proyecto de renta global el
mandatario también anunció que impulsará
la legalización de la marihuana para uso
recreativo en los primeros tres meses de
gobierno más del 70% de la población
está de acuerdo con el trabajo de chávez
según las más recientes encuestas